[Music]
good afternoon everyone thanks for
coming so let's get started so how many
of you attended the keynote session
today awesome lot of great announcements
today especially in the data analytics
space this session is going to focus on
two key announcements which is bi engine
and connected sheets so we're going to
go deeper into why we build bi engine
what are the what is the value
proposition what is connected sheets
offer and we will have a customer Oratia
chief product officer Nick ang who is
going to show a demonstration of how bi
engine and connected sheets has helped
AirAsia become a data focused
organization so let's get started so if
you look at bi today business
intelligence today it's still a critical
workload for a lot of organizations lot
of key day-to-day decisions depend on
access to business intelligence tools
but yet IT makes it it's harder for IT
to manage and scale business
intelligence infrastructure there are a
lot of vendor solutions and every
department has their own solutions to do
this and it makes it very hard for them
to scale make sure all the readers
available on time to do that and this
statistic shows that about 24% back in
2009 had access to BI tools within the
organization and since then it has grown
to about 35% with self-service bi but
still there is a gap and we've heard
this from customers of bigquery today
lot of customers who use bigquery today
still have to take the data out of
bigquery create a data Mart run extra
extracts or manage a bi server to do
their reporting and dashboard the second
thing is customers want us to have fast
interactive experience for their
dashboards sub-second query latency so
they can visually interact with the data
make decisions at the same time they
also want access to fresh data so they
don't want to compromise between data
freshness and speed they won't have
access to real-time data so that
decisions can be made on time and lastly
customers want to expose those data sets
their key metrics to broader sort of
users within the organization so bi is
more available to more users so they can
access to data sets so how many of you
she use sheets today or some sort of
spreadsheets so this recent study done
by the sheets team shows that sheets is
still a top dog with an enterprise lot
of users use sheets as a way to do
lightweight business analyst business
intelligence analysis and lightweight
data wrangling and really the
opportunity we have in front of us is to
really fill this gap so bi becomes lot
more pervasive within the organization
lot more users have access to BI tools
as opposed to are getting restricted to
some sort of few users within the
organization so this is built on what
Google believes in Google's believes in
organizing world's information and
making it accessible and we believe that
we want to have the same experience with
business intelligence we want to offer
that cost the first party experience
with dear studio and sheets at the same
time support partner solutions like
tableau looker so customers have the
choice which they can use for business
intelligence we want to enable bi on big
data so that customers can explore big
datasets but without compromising on
scale or speed collaboration is a big
part of what we do with business
intelligence we want to make sure
customers can share the data set
securely within the organization with
their partners with their vendors
without having to worry about security
challenges and lastly this notion of
blending in AI and machine learning into
bi so that he can do predictive
analytics is key I was talking to a
recent CIO who said who didn't have a
good handle on the BI infrastructure but
he said if I put ml everything going
everything will become easy I can do
predictions but that's not true because
you need to have a solid foundation of
business intelligence from a data
management perspective otherwise you're
going to make lot of bad decisions but
you will be doing it with more
confidence right so you want to make
sure that bi is the foundation layer on
which you can layer machine learning and
AI and this is if you look at our
reference architecture with with with
GCP we have simplified solutions across
all different phases of BI right from
ingestion whether you're ingesting from
on-premise sources or cloud sources we
have bunch different set of products
which allows you to do
different ingestion experience for
example we have data flow we have cloud
data fusion which we announced today
which is about ETL we have big data
transfer query transfer service for SAS
connectors we have data proc and we have
a bunch of partner solutions as well all
the data goes into bigquery which is our
petabyte scale data warehouse on which
we have data catalog for metadata
service and we have data prep for data
wrangling from there you can query the
data set using bigquery sequel interface
or use data studio sheets and also
partner solutions like tableau looker
etc right but our goal is to make
business intelligent infrastructure
management easy so that it's invisible
so you can focus lot more on asking
questions interacting with your data set
in a much more faster manner so today we
announce bigquery BI engine and bigquery
bi engine is really helping users to
have the scale which they expect in a in
a bi bi scenario so in this the key goal
with bigquery bi engine is to
democratize bi so that your data analyst
and business analysts can do real-time
interactive analytics at scale without
having to compromise on data freshness
or speed right and so bigquery bi engine
is an in-memory engine in in-memory
analysis engine which is built into
bigquery right so that allows you to do
sub-second query responses for some of
your business intelligent queries at
high concurrency right so some of the
key aspects of bigquery behind Xion is
that sub-second queries it simplifies
the architecture now you don't have to
move data outside of bigquery to any of
your data Mart's or run complex extracts
it's built into bigquery and lastly it
it has some query optimizations done for
some of the BI use cases so that your
queries are really optimized as you
start scaling your dashboards so let's
go into each of them individually so
sub-second queries so bi engine is a
column oriented in-memory analysis
engine built into bigquery bigquery is a
column oriented data store and bi engine
is a column oriented in-memory engine it
can scale horizontally so as more users
access your dashboards and reports it
can replicate data horizontally to
multiple nodes so it can support all
your concurrent code
is much more faster and the last one is
an important one bigquery BIA engine
natively integrates with bigquery
streaming so as data gets streamed into
your infrastructure into a bigquery
table it can do aggregation right on the
streaming buffer so your total latency
from the event coming in to bigquery
versus showing up in your dashboard is
in seconds not minutes or hours right so
that sort of makes the whole real time
experience for dashboards much more
faster second one is it's built on
bigquery storage and because of which it
eliminates the need for managing any BI
servers or running extracts or running a
data Mart it automatically decides what
kind of data sets to be used and it
automatically loads it into an in-memory
OLAP cube so you don't have to really
create any OLAP engine or manage that we
sort of create an supercharged OLAP cube
on the fly and then expose that to your
dashboards and our key goal here is also
to be open to partners so we will have
an open API which is a simple sequel
interface so that tools like looker and
tableau or any of the open source tools
you can connect to BI engine through
sequel interface and still get the same
experience a last one is smart tuning so
bi engine has a query optimizer built in
which looks at your bi specific query
and optimizes that for example it uses
the right sort of encoding it
understands what sort of queries you're
using so it can do compression or it may
not do compression based on your group
buy or other clauses and lastly all of
this capacity management for BI engine
is built into bigquery UI starting today
so if you go to a big query UI you will
see a new option called bi engine where
you can decide how much capacity you
need for your for your bi use cases so
it automatically takes all those columns
which you create from later studio loads
it into memory and any of the data
queries which come from data studio is
served from the BI engine video we don't
use bigquery slots so you sort of make
good trade-off between how much what
kind of concurrency or query latency you
need versus what how many slots you want
to use so you can make this seamless
trade-off based on your use case and
it's as simple as going and discerning
how much capacity you need for the
project and then that it automatically
does that for you
and all these metrics about how much
data is coming from bigquery OLAP cubes
is all surfaced and stackdriver so you
can see what is Aquarian latency you can
decide how much of this coming from the
in-memory engine was a slot so you can
decide how much capacity you want to add
more versus reduce so this look at a
quick look at bigquery architecture this
is the bigquery architecture today which
we have shared it with you for years
it's really what makes bigquery a
petabyte scale data warehouse is the
separation of storage and compute with a
petabyte network which makes with what
bigquery is but what we're adding today
with BI engine is a stateful execution
layer on top of the same bigquery
storage the stateful execution layer
actually maintains the state of all your
data sets so that when you access that
from a dashboard tool like data studio
or sheets it can do the smart
optimization in memory versus going back
to bigquery storage and it can
automatically maintain this adaptive
cache between the storage layer and the
in-memory layer so let's go one level
deeper and see how it works so behind bi
engine there is a semantic model so we
create a semantic model comprising of
your metadata it has a calculation API
which data studio uses today and it
maintains this all that semantic model
in memory and when the query comes the
intelligent memory manager looks at the
query and looks at what optimizations
can be done and if it can be done within
the in-memory layer it actually does all
those optimizations like picking the
right encoding picking the right
compression format and serves that from
the query and then cannot if it doesn't
do that it automatically fails over two
slots right so it automatically decides
what can optimization can be done it
will do it if not it'll use slots and
that's what makes the initial set of
small queries much more faster it when
I'm talking about like millisecond
latency is what you get from this engine
so how how's the pricing for this the
pricing is very similar to how big
queries price today there's an on demand
here and there's a flat tier so for on
demand it starts at one gig and you can
add in increments of 1 gig capacity and
it's about point 0 for 1 6 GB per hour
or it roughly translates to 30
three $6 per gig per month right and I
said earlier whenever any query comes
from the BI engine capacity we don't use
slot so you're not paying for the per
query cost which you see in bigquery so
you make those trade-offs based on your
use case and if you're a flat-rate
customer we pre bundle the BI engine
capacity for every tier so if you are a
500 slot customer we give you 25 gives
gigs of capacity if you're a 2000 slot
tier we give you 100 gigs of capacity
and if you want anything more you can
pay based on the per gig cost which is
on that on which is on the left side so
today in beta
we are not enabling billing so you can
experience bi engine for your use case
up to 10 gigs you can try it out see how
it works for your use case but once we
start enabling billing sometime in July
we will increase the capacity so you can
sort of get bigger capacity sizes as
well so we've been using bi engine for
trying working with customers for many
last few months and we've got some great
feedback and it has helped us improve
this whole engine as well so when desta
is a customer I met at next last year
we're doing a session on how billing how
showing the billing dashboards in their
studio notice little slower to load so
we worked with them and got them onto
the BI engine alpha program they worked
with us and since then it has
dramatically changed the way that the
dashboard latencies are right from
minutes - it has come down to like
military seconds and they're slowly
going to roll out this to their internal
users and as well as to their end
customers so we seen that success with
Zalando as well so zalando is a
ecommerce leader in europe so they had
this internal supply chain dashboard
which all of their suppliers use to look
at their use cases how much goods are
being sold on their website what
channels are effective and they wanted
that very interactive experience for
their business stakeholders and product
managers to make those decisions by
using the BI engine they were able to
get to that level of query Layton sees
and they are able to roll it out to a
set of users and today they have about
800 users within the organization using
data studio and they're going to expand
that to lot more users again going back
to demo
rising bi and making it accessible to a
lot more users last one is a fortune 500
media company and they sort of create a
sort of a news data warehouse for their
journalists and editors so there they
can look at what channels are being used
and what is the more effective way to
market their Newspeak news pieces so
they provided a dashboard on data studio
to their internal users running on bi
engine and they get they were able to
get a lot more faster experience for
their users so with that I also want to
introduce the next piece of
democratizing B is connected sheets so
connected sheet is a is way you use
sheets as an interface but it's connect
it's backed by bigquery right so it
maintains a live connection with
bigquery so you without any knowledge of
sequel with minimum knowledge of sequel
you can just drag and drop create pivot
tables do filtering apply formulas with
just few clicks and because of the whole
G sweet experience of sharing and
collaboration experience share securely
your sheets with lot more users within
the organization so so that we don't
have to worry about exporting data to a
sheet and giving it to different people
over emails you can do that securely but
it's since it's backed by bigquery it
can do analysis on a large data set
which was not possible earlier right so
we've super excited about connected
sheets again in moving for will have
beta sometime in 29 end of 2019 and at
that point connected sheet will also use
bigquery bi engine as their underlying
engine so you get the same experience of
sub-second query latency on a big data
set with the interactive experience so
that you can roll out your bi use cases
to lot more will users within the
organization so with that let me
introduce Nikunj nikunj is the chief
product officer of AirAsia and they've
been a great advocate of bigquery and
they've been using all our early
versions of product and given a skate
feedback so with that let me hand it off
to him to showcase how bi engine and
connected sheets has impacted his
organization okay
[Applause]
all right so a little bit background
AirAsia is a low-cost airline based in
Southeast Asia we're in our
transformation program we're working on
AirAsia 3.0 which is really about taking
the airline to the next level which is
more than beyond flights is really about
selling customers other things that they
might need in their journey such as
hotels activities and other
complementary things that go beyond the
flight and to do that we have to really
become a digital airline really leverage
the data that we have over the history
of AirAsia we've flown over five hundred
million passengers and we want to start
going on to the neck spirits of
personalizing their experiences from
booking ticking booking in ticketing and
then the second thing is really in the
airline world you still see a lot of
paper being used and it's about
digitizing that paper so we can do a lot
more data flows across the board and
click compare and complete the data loop
so we'll talk a little bit about that as
we go on but the whole goal is to get
areas to the areas of 3.0 which is
really around going beyond flights and
selling other opportunities and so just
a little bit background on AirAsia we
were a very very large airline group in
Southeast Asia number four by numbers in
Asia 260 aircraft three and sixty routes
190 unique destinations so unique means
that we're it only once flying that
route which gives us a a great view on
you know where customers want to go 140
destinations in 24 countries we fly
around 90 million passengers so that you
can imagine that's a lot of personal
information but also a lot of
information about customers that don't
actually book and transact with us but
we have a lot of detailed information
there and during a lifetime we have 500
million customers and and our staff is
is quite intensive as well we have
24,000 staff which we call love stars
and so as Ares just going to the next
trajectory we're transforming from an
airline company to a digital company and
technologies and data is quite important
for that we're trying to build a brand
that will go beyond ASEAN and we have a
five-year plan for airshow 3.0 which is
really to go
flights and then we want to be leading
the pack on innovation and pioneering so
we're really using data as a key lever
to be able to do that and we'll talk a
little bit more on how that works within
the AirAsia so in terms of data we've
been collecting data for a long time
there's so many places that you can
collect information you can kind of see
how that it's listed out here there's
always emails loyalty programs the
actual ticketing booking profiles of
customers for what they like what they
don't like do they like to buy see we
sell ala carte seats meals bags so we
have a lot of preferential data on what
customers like and based on their routes
we see a lot of different behaviors or
happening and we want to be able to use
that data to help personalize what's
going on we have social media activity
with the event of mobile we have a lot
more on location tracking and how people
are using as you can imagine people that
book on mobile have a different profile
and people that book on desktop so we're
taking advantage of all that data we
spent a lot of time for the last three
years really normalizing and putting all
that data into bigquery to be able to
build that foundation so that we can
make really good use cases come out of
it and some of those are really turning
out new and I'll talk about a couple of
them that the team are working on that
really helped for our operations as well
so there's a couple couple folks working
on a couple use cases around meal
planning and things like that and then
all of this really our end goal is
really to collect information throughout
the whole journey as much as possible
we're very guests obsessed we want to
really drive our guests experience
higher and our goal is to have a really
high NPS score and we're using all these
different touch points really completing
the data loop as you can imagine many
many airlines just focus on one part or
another part we want to really focus on
the end-to-end journey and really
capture all feedback and experience that
happens what when people are just doing
discovery which is before search but
also when they come to the website where
they search for how many times already
searching how do we make this a little
bit better and faster how do we market
the right information to customers so we
really need a really solid foundation to
be able to collect that data and
bigquery has really provided us that
foundation and based on that we're able
to customize and do a little bit more
beyond on the search side but also on
the operations
we're working on there and then from the
data management to data-driven outcomes
right so we we have a lot of data that
comes in we have descripted analytics
which are really around business
intelligence and reporting which is
standard what most companies have and
we're making that a lot easier and
trying to democratize that data so I'll
show you some of the examples that we
have with data studio and in sheets
connected sheets how that works we have
some other situations on the left on
diagnostic analytics which is really
around how to improve the operations or
how to sell more we're working on what
might happen which is around do we put
extra meals on a plane or do we keep
them out there because every time we put
extra meal we think we might be able to
sell more about just doing more
announcements and etc but that's not
always the case and - can we use ml to
be really optimize our wastage on the
plane so there's some really good
examples and use cases beyond that and
then what's the next best action so
depending on your demographic your
profile if you're flying for a short
haul flight that's only less than 75
minutes would you really want to buy a
meal or would you be more interested in
boarding and leaving them playing first
and so based on that information we can
make different techniques in status
based on your preferences and also show
different results to use there on a
website so we've we incorporated all
those types of techniques onto the
website so if you do use area comm
you'll see many of those things and if
you're on a plane and that's being being
leveraging a ml model for food you'll
see that the food wastage is very low on
that plane because we're able to ensure
that we don't have extra extra weight
because of the food but extra we're not
losing money because of the wastage here
so that's that's all being taken care of
so we're really using our data and
trying to drive outcomes that come out
of it okay and so the key things that
happen on the areas of transformation is
really we want to elect I mention before
the airline has a lot of paper processes
so we need to go ahead and digitize that
information once we start digitizing the
information we can start to see patterns
right and we can really start making
minor adjustments to it and so to be
able to go optimize that stuff so that's
part of that transformation we we've
gone through organizational changes to
enable that process we've started to
move a lot of our data to the cloud
once the data is in the cloud we can do
a couple automations to really check on
our hypothesis and see if that's really
happening we move to agile structure so
that commercial teams and marketing
teams and technology teams are really
moving quicker and being able to produce
outcomes and really instead of taking
months to do something we can do
something in in weeks to see if our
hypotheses are working correctly and
then we do it again so it's a
full-circle process if we find something
else we continue to continue the process
there and what why did we chose or
choose Google cloud platform well back
when we started a journey bigquery was
the leader in the space back then and
still was a leader now in terms of
processing data its obsession queries
actually getting information into
bigquery it's very straightforward and
I'll talk a little bit about down and
cost as a low cost airline cost is quite
important for us and being able to
decouple query and storage is quite
important and then the no-ops
model of big queries is is great so that
our developers can go ahead and develop
infrastructure or data sets but also ETL
processes so they don't have to worry
about an infrastructure guy spending up
a new database that's not a problem and
then being able to do many many queries
in background so they're not waiting for
you know who's priority of the query
goes first right that's not a problem
anymore that was a problem that we had
before and so all of that is solved by
the Google platform but as we develop
more and more things on Google all the
data sits in one place and then we're
able to combine it in bigquery to be
able to do a lot more use cases right
and so our our solution architecture
here is is it's built this way you know
I'll walk you through a little bit more
so you understand how it works we have
our DMS I think most most customers have
our DMS is out there our DMS is a very
old windows technology our DMS I'll say
and we need to get the data out of there
and so we have some connectors with the
ETL over here in the middle we use
composer in that scenario to get data
out of there and we load it into
bigquery we have flat files that come
out for many other third party data that
we have when we're doing pricing
comparisons we
use third-party acquisition court
sources and we get some data from there
again that goes through a pub sub so
that we can automatically load it into
bigquery via a notification we have data
from flower store for our no sequel data
and that goes through cloud functions
whenever updates happens so that goes
into bigquery and any other data that's
automatically produce from GCP so our
App Engine logs and other things around
there we can go ahead and naturally put
into bigquery and that makes it a lot
easier for us to have a centralized
place in and then what we do from there
is really have some processes on cloud
functions or
a composer or other scripts that we have
that really start massaging that data
into data Mart's that we need or a big
big data leak in bigquery so we can
start looking at an individual profile
so we can look at an individual user and
see their history and pattern if you've
logged in to understand what we need to
personalize or we go ahead and do
attribute scoring that we need to do to
provide you route what that route really
wants or an example of cart loading is
based on who's flying what type of meals
might be needed to sell that all that
goes bigquery we and for archiving
purposes we we store a snapshot of every
day in this cloud storage so if we want
to roll back in time and see what
happened we can go back and go load up
that snapshot from cloud storage so that
a lot of times things you know as you
can imagine the airline is a moving
state operation and things that were the
status three weeks ago might have now
put the status of a ticket and you don't
want to you you don't want to store a
live repository that we can just go
snapshot in time and see what that
ticket state was a couple weeks before
and see what's happening there now all
of that actually goes into our delivery
and digestion insights delivery we we
have two primary tools data studio and
sheets and we're recently we've been
able to cut down on some of the other
tools that we use just the products have
gotten so much better and they're
continually improving and they are
helping us reduce our dependency on
third party tools so we have data studio
and data sheets on that and then out of
bigquery we're able to do machine
learning we use some of that data again
for personal experience
with App Engine it goes into another GCP
core tools as data flow and compute as
your data flow we kind of use really for
you know how many people are searching
for a route and etc and we can you do a
lot of stuff with that data there that
comes in real time so that's kind of how
it works there and then we'll go into a
demo and I'll show you some of the two
products that we use in how how they're
used on the in real life so one of the
dashboards that our market here is use
quite a lot is you know what the
nationally flown dashboard I think we
saw a demo of that the data itself has
been changed a little bit so for anyone
that's wants to know we've changed all
the airport's out so what you're seeing
is in some of the metrics out we've
changed some of that out so it's not
real area it's area data but the names
are us names so it's very easy so if you
know airport code you'll probably see
very familiar names here but this
dashboard is really used by marketeers
to go ahead and know what type of people
are flying on the fly what is happening
in terms of the number of passengers
flown and typically they were getting
this dashboard via email once a month
and now when we moved it over to the
bigquery engine and a pipelines that we
have we're able to go ahead and
distribute this daily and customers or
end clients can help go ahead and drill
down and use that so I'll go to example
here we have the date range but if I was
interested in let's go ahead and say my
nationality I can just click on that
it's using the BI engine in the
background and filters everything pretty
quickly and if I was interested in this
floral arrow' they're all route I can go
ahead and click on that and it's up
seconds goes ahead and changes the data
across which is fantastic because when
when you're in a meeting you can refer
to this dashboard as the Bible and
everyone's looking at the same thing so
you can get up to many many users on
this is a copy of the real one so
obviously there's only one person on it
right now but when we're in meetings you
can get up to like a lot of a lot of
people I mean we have around you know
Dow's in to people folks in marketing
and commercial so you can imagine we can
get about two
hundred people looking at this on a
daily basis not all confirmed but
concurrently I usually see around 50 to
60 people using and now with bi engine
the way that it works it really makes it
easy and fast for people to go ask that
question and leave the meeting with real
concrete action items versus actually
waiting for a report back and asking a
question and then having another meeting
on a report so it works quite well we
let me just reset everything and you can
see here as I filter along it's pretty
responsive and fast and how it works so
it's it's quite impressive for us so but
a lot of times you know the pre Kamdesh
boards that we have aren't enough for
our market ears they want to ask more
questions right so and the the ultimate
tool that they use still is a
spreadsheet right because they want to
see some underlying data and they want
to get you a couple more things so what
happens is our bi teams they usually get
tasked with data pukes right and data
puke is really an extraction information
because it's really hard for us for them
to go write a sequel query to get to
this information with the upcoming
release of connected sheets we can go
ahead and provide a lot more
self-service so this is a demo sheet
that we put together we'll look at some
of the questions that we have here you
know and some of the question is is it's
great the dashboard looks great but we
need something more on capacity and pax
loans so I'll show you example of that
in the dashboard it doesn't have that
very easily for someone to see it's
there but it's not a hundred percent
exactly in the form that they want and
they'll ask some particular questions
I'll just go through an example of what
they do there the data that we're going
to use is we're going to use this data
set here so let me just go to the live
one and you can see it's around 12
million rows we yeah we have a lot of
data sets are about a hundred million
rows as well and then you can imagine a
marketeer will have a tough time taking
this and putting this into a spreadsheet
it's just too heavy for a spreadsheet to
use so how do we solve that with
connected sheets I'll try a a a brand
new one so I'll just show you the
process so if you go to data data
connectors connect you cheat here
let's see if it it's fast enough yeah
there's a lot of people on Wi-Fi here so
it's a little slow but we'll go to our
demo dataset and so it's it's as you can
tell it's going straight against
bigquery here and going against that and
it actually pulls the data here this is
great this is the raw data it doesn't
show you all 12 million rows it just
gives you an idea of what's going on and
then we'll go ahead and do a pivot table
as most marketers want to do and the
question that they want to know is like
Florida oil how has it been growing in
terms of Pax nationality and we can kind
of add that for the last two years so we
can go ahead and add some rows to show
that and what we'll do here is group it
by month add some columns and group it
by year and we'll add in packs phloem is
that was the question and then we'll add
in a filter that the text contains and
so if you know airport codes Florida LS
FLL I think I'm not really in the US
market but I think that's it and if you
hit the apply button it does some magic
behind the scenes and you get some
information there and you can see how
that actually flows out and you can ask
more questions reveries aliy here but
the magic behind this is really it did
execute a query and if we go to our
query history oops
should i refresh yeah let me refresh
hopefully it won't take too long if it
doesn't I shouldn't refresh this you
tapped it but you can see here it did
the query that's here and then if you if
did previously this type of analysis and
work would have required a a data
analyst to go ahead and write this query
for the marketing guy and that causes a
delay and then you have to go ahead and
prioritize some effort here but now with
this type of work you're able to execute
the query on the fly in a connected
sheet so that they can get this type of
information very fast and easy and they
can continue on with their questions
without interrupting the more complex
work that a bi analyst might need to go
do so this is this is this is the next
evolution of data analysis that AirAsia
and will be able to do a lot more
democracy ssin of the data that we've
already flattened and built in bigquery
so that's the end of the demo oh do I
have one yeah is it there oh sorry okay
so and then what this really means in
terms of the impact is we've we can use
the data in bigquery to reduce our
operating cost and like example I told
you is really you know waste HR meals we
can go ahead and solve that zero hours
in terms of managing servers we don't
have to wait we are actually
everything's up and running faster
previously in most ETL jobs if you're in
the data warehousing world you only
reprocess X amount of days in history
with the infrastructure that we have in
place I put two years of data but we can
go in many years and we can process that
in minutes usually we can do the whole
ETL job very very fast historically most
companies only process seven years or
thirty days of or seven days or 30 days
of historical data on a run we can go
ahead and reprocess the whole cube so
that allows us to keep the raw data and
then go ahead and run our ETL pipeline
so that we get faster Corrections or
faster reports out and then all of this
is can be shared and used by the 1500
plus knowledge workers that we have we
have a lot of folks that are running the
operations of the plane they don't need
really access to a lot of this raw data
but as we expose a lot more data about
customer behavior etc we'll be expanding
all everyone will be able to access a
lot more information so your cabin crew
that serving your hot meal will know
like your preference whether you like a
coke or a diet coke you don't have to
ask that question it'll just give you
that beverage of choice that you need
because that's where people are
expecting that type of behavior if
they've been ordering coke for the last
five years you kind
know what they want so we can go ahead
and distribute this data a lot more
around the scenes there yeah thank you
so much yeah so so what he just saw was
how Alicia was able to use the
capability of connected sheets with BI
engine and scales bi - lot more users
within the organization so just - right
wrap it up I just want to provide a
quick road map update on where things
are so today we we are announcing beta
with data studio for bi engine the
reservations that we're not turn on
you're not turning on billing so it's
you cannot use up to 10 gigs but
sometime in July we will turn on billing
well we have give you more capacity so
you can decide you can create bigger
data models and GA is around q4 where we
will integrate bi engine with connected
sheets as well so you get the same sort
of fast performance share the data model
within studio and sheets but as I said
earlier we we take a very partner
oriented approach in this as well so
there will be an open API which will be
simple sequel interface and we working
with tableau and looker and other bi
vendors to integrate this BI engine with
with with with other front ends as well
so that's absolutely plan in the roadmap
and that'll be available sometime early
q1 maybe q4 as well so call to action
try bi engine it's available for you
starting today it's a you will be see
that in the bigquery UI you can use data
studio to connect to that there's also a
session I think right after this which
talks about all the new features of data
studio how data studio is evolving as a
visualization solution a lot of new
features as well so I encourage you to
attend that we did have a session
earlier today on sheets all the
different ways sheets can be used so we
have recorded that so do watch it and
also when you're in Asia fly ratio thank
you all have a great session
[Music]